hello and welcome to this video playing
Pandora's box 13 I already played a
couple of games
hey let's go 93
any place he placed my own repertoire
just I just neglected I just declined
any invitation to a turban oniy this
looks very
yeah like a very sensible option just
develop to normal squares and claim to
have a small admittedly small advantage
well that looks nice I like the sir
position for me if I if it does not want
to play it seems
okay
let's try to exert some pressure on the
queenside
maybe it's just Queen to b6 it's
definitely a possibility
sometimes tricky to to assess if Queen
b6 is a good move or not the weaknesses
like if I take on b6 the weaknesses on
b6 their b7 they look a little bit of
ugly image in fact it very often is
impossible to exploit them yeah this is
certainly a wise option and actually now
that I look edit it does not doesn't
look great for me
but maybe it's fine I mean moving the
rook is kind of a anon anon movie a
looksie forever I mean I Roxy for Queen
a1 it doesn't help them at all night c4
I still might just take b7 and my dad at
that looks wrong
wrong okay first look to the sea farm
maybe the other one but these are the
decisions which route to take
where that you can spend time on in a
tournament game and a classical town car
okay but in the Blitz game just make a
move that feels right here I think it's
more likely that rook FC 1 is right so
because inform a5 that there are
scenarios where it might make sense to
have the look on a 1 this is a bit odd
97 I mean my idea was nice b5 anyway and
ask him about all those pawns so let's
do it
I mean a7 all those parts are a 7 so
that was not very precise way to coined
it but um how does he cover it
the night on f5 is also a bit stranded
if I get into play pawn to before it
might not have a single square to go to
you
yeah 97 was the idea
unfortunately taking on ch does not do
anything good
I hadn't stood thinking about this for
too long could be costly in the long run
I think it was a vote taken see one book
see one and then the night only 7 is a
bit weird it has very little squares but
always have C 6 huh interesting
like
it could be a good move
this is a good move a Kim
not too happy him
ah
I'm threatening no he does not really do
much about it about my idea but maybe
there was not much that was possible in
the first place so I'm grabbing the
spawn and
yeah it's a bit of a problem now for
black that if you would be able to play
like rook c8 and just activate
but the pollen a6 is just hanging and I
don't think you can just give it up it's
tough to imagine that you can sacrifice
it okay so he is covering
yeah that's a good move
you know that looks like a good movie so
how do we how do we play this I would
like to activate my rook he's not
threatening all that much so I think
Roxy one should be feasible step out of
checks so that potentially I can move
the rook away from the back ring
yeah like rooks e7 moves like that could
be a point well here actually Bishop h4
instead of move
maybe if I play looks III where's the
Queen going
Quincy one he talked like that
this is annoying and then the rook does
not have all that many good squares
unfortunately there is not
don't see anything fantastic maybe
Bishop f6
Oh
not saying it it's fantastic but
maybe Bishop FC
but actually the other thing of it might
not be the most effective thing
you
and taking a five
that's going to be difficult okay tries
to trade I can't check first that I
think
and now probably I don't want to trade
want to keep a bit more pressure but I
have ten seconds this is a bit of a
problem
maybe you can go Queenie - just like
that
Wow
here didn't see that and no no I should
be winning no even with my technical
abilities that should be doable
all right yeah let's let's have a look
down I am not so happy here you know I
think here okay I should be a bit better
here now after Queen before b6 no I
should have a pretty sizable advantage
but it did not play it correctly so look
FC one okay engine gives you a c1 or
Bishop e2 there should be two is a very
very good move that I did not consider
it this looked fine on a diagonal but
here it makes a lot of sense covering
here and I can go to a six and this is a
key idea if I get the bishop to a six
then I will basically be sure to control
the C file and this is obviously quite
important the letters of strong news
that I did not pay attention to so I
went here you played 97 and now I should
improve probably because that night B's
587 that is not giving me enough the
engine prefers this and gives it a wind
it's a position that I thought of course
but
now here here probably something like
rook d7 a such an enormous threat and
I'm threatening indeed Knight xe7 that
is true the engine seized of course more
than I do like here if you check this
take take and now Queen takes is very
strong because I have this before threat
winning the night and then it has no
squares this absolutely every square
covered and he cannot stop before I'm
getting this back with interest so this
is very very strong in fact very strong
it seems like I made a blunder somewhere
where was the blunder I completely
understand that I've made mistakes but
I'm not question where the blunders okay
so I would not be five and now after a
six yeah I went to this this journey
that it is better for Wyatt I mean it's
tough to tour destroyed it but this is
not really yeah it's just a pawn it's
not a huge crush or anything he five
take take 23 Roxy gone that looks very
normal and I'm happy up to this point
and now rooks is six is given by the
comp simply tried to pick up the second
Pole I have thought about it but I
didn't feel a greediness readiness greed
is a good choice here but probably it
works okay me this keeps a lot lot of an
advance a lot of the advantage so look
ahead is better but okay as a human you
see her with little time but I still
wonder where the blunder exactly is
Queen b3 best move was before
this is actually interesting h4 is a
good more
yes the idea to take on g3 and then
activate crude Queen d2 and activate as
a yeah
wouldn't have been all that easy
probably I'm okay but still
okay queen is six so we got to the rook
ending and okay rook d6 was bad
oh pretty nice Queen King King e6 got
bad because of the a dead of a blunder
yeah of course I can't bend the rook no
I was just like main pretty moving
basically yeah I knew that
pledge for you and I mean it's probably
a technical win and in any case but I
fail to I've put it away immediately the
interesting point is really 95 instead
of night b5 that's something that I
should point out that this is very
strong in fact sometimes with the ideas
that b4 will trap the knight on the edge
of the board okay guys thanks for
watching